rogue in on his carnivore diet we got to
Felix best pasta in the world was he
farting no he's like he's like no I only
eat steak best steak that steak a stupid
stupid idea
oh we got to come anytime yeah whatever
I invited you that night I invited you
you said it Charlotte
no Charlie dude I invited you the night
before for dinner but either way it was
like I'm gonna take you there cuz she'll
you know it'll knock your dick in the
dirt the pasta if I don't know that mom
dude I'm like Rogan dude are you doing a
caramel meat I eat carbs in the morning
though so so but of course rogue and the
extremists
I gotta [ __ ] hear about the wonders
of the carnivore diet now yeah and but
what maybe you know for a while it
probably is really I don't think it's
sustainable I don't think you do it for
a year oh I need some jaime duque doe
for that long at the time but you how
about how about [ __ ] I have chills so
low on food truck diary
are you already can eat yes did I watch
that podcast with Rogen right now back
he was now doing carnivore like what the
[ __ ]
so even he ate carnivore kind of he had
some yeah everybody's doing this I guess
III I don't know I don't know have even
seen the [ __ ] rolling skin for thing
he's gonna go with Bernie Sanders yeah
of course look Joe Rogan has become we
were talking about the other day and
he's he Carson but he's more than bigger
he's more than that because he's become
one of the most influential people in
the world he just actually has with his
podcast he just is and what part of it
is because he's not trying to be the guy
doesn't part of us the guy doesn't
[ __ ] he doesn't heat but he won't
have certain politicians on he won't
have allies people on because he doesn't
believe them because they're selling a
narrative
hey wait and not getting on show is to
try to get on the show yeah exactly
he's a myth take notes you [ __ ] walk
away from an off yesterday here's the
thing it's his show you [ __ ] you do
whatever he harassed correct if he
believes Bernie's his guy
Bernice's and by the way when he says
that what he's saying is that at least
with already had a kind of believes him
because he met him yeah rogue is not a
socialist or a liberal in that sense
he's he's but he's a lot of different
things you can't be he's saying
something he goes I might vote for it's
an idea that he's playing around
fighting me how upset people
I love it I love it I love it I love it
first thing you know I'm not a Bernie
fan but I listen tome on Rogen at least
he's consistent and tells the truth I
don't like uni these [ __ ] how
about that I don't like any of them
none of them are great yeah none of it I
I mean you're basically picking out and
pic picture poison none of them are
great he's got this little beef with
Steve and I Samantha not gonna beef but
Smith I sent your father's needle you
know now I do cuz I followed it Steven
Smith called cowboy on my face dude I
don't I don't want to date your birthday
bro I will take that doughnut and shove
it down your stupid old rocking face
because you're not gonna get away with
the [ __ ] moves you did you know it
they were [ __ ] moves all right cool
he'd called Joe Donald Cerrone Donald
over voice running - great he's running
he called him a quitter yeah I know
he called him a quitter now you called
Donald Cerrone I'm glad dude when I
heard that I was like you're out you
don't know you don't know anything about
MMA no shut the [ __ ] up and and that's
sacrilege you don't call Donald Cerrone
a quitter but and then even his rebuttal
to Rogan he's off at least he can throw
a hook though dude huge [ __ ] you up
Hey look at me B I'm not being real
shitty I'm saying if there's like a
celebrity I yeah hey [ __ ] you let's see
that let's see that let's see that
awesome hug its Peter both coming off
the ground looks like a dick punch and
again the left chef more makeup on all
right guys had some is that gone the
left the Joker no look at this look at
this who's the middle it's just weird
right he's not an ass he's never done a
sport in his life he's one of the best
[ __ ] journalists in the game he's
amazing but stick to that hey the guy
left Joe new Joker huh that's cool Wow
he's had some work oh yeah just got cast
as the Riddler new Batman it's a guy
who's trying to keep his skin tight
Brennan take it in tight this is the
problem with with cell there's a problem
with men who get plastic surgery in
their 40s and 50s don't do it so yeah
you know what you're not under the head
does he suck dick well you know you're
noticing there that his forehead is too
smooth and doesn't move
and he should have a cream it's not
yours
and I'm looking at yours I'm looking at
his and it's like ask get some tips from
my friend woody I don't understand what
you're saying
do you give all the wrinkles right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]